[Music]
think about all of the stuff in the
universe
from the particles of dust on your
screen to the billions of planets and
galaxies you see in the night sky
everything you could possibly imagine
all the observable matter in the
universe
is only five percent of what's really
out there
everything else is dark
a property of most normal matter is that
it interacts with electromagnetic
radiation
or light this means that when light
reaches an object it is typically
absorbed or reflected
this interaction allows us to detect
this matter
dark matter on the other hand doesn't
interact with light at all
rendering it invisible so if we can't
see dark matter
what makes scientists believe it's there
it all has to do with another property
of matter the effect it has on other
matter in the universe
we call this phenomenon gravity and
experience it as
pull that the mass of the sun exerts on
the planets around it
keeping the earth in orbit when any two
objects orbit each other
this gravitational pull is what keeps
them from flying apart
the faster two objects are orbiting each
other the more mass we expect them to
have
in 1933 astronomer fritz zwicky
noted something extraordinary while
studying a cluster of galaxies
he measured how fast the galaxies were
moving around each other
and used this to estimate their mass
when he compared his estimate to the
observable mass of the galaxies
he found that it was 400 times larger he
argued that there must be some missing
or invisible mass and called it dark
matter
allowing them to orbit so fast without
flying apart
the phenomenon has since been observed
and verified by other scientists
in many different galaxies including our
own
but the speedy orbiting isn't the only
reason scientists believe dark matter
exists
another phenomenon related to mass is
that it affects the way light moves
through the universe
in a phenomenon called gravitational
lensing light bends around massive
objects as it travels near them through
space
the more massive the object the greater
the bending
by observing the light coming from
distant stars scientists have measured
stronger than expected bending around
galaxies
indicating that the galaxies have more
mass than we can see
more evidence for this missing matter
so what is it well since we can't
observe it scientists aren't really sure
but there are a number of theories as to
what it might be
one theory is that dark matter is made
up of massive compact halo objects or
machos mantras are very large
up to thousands of times larger than the
sun collections of normal matter that do
not typically interact with light
and thus are not visible physicists
observe
these objects through other phenomena
related to their gravity
black holes are an example of such
objects and can only be detected by the
way the light
and matter collect around them
unfortunately black holes and other
machos
seem to exist only in distinct pockets
in the universe
whereas observations show that dark
matter is spread out more evenly in
space
so many physicists reject the theory
instead many physicists believe that
undiscovered particles are what
constitutes dark matter
theory and other parts of physics
require the existence of a special group
of particles called wimps
weakly interacting massive particles
scientists expect them to have certain
properties
mass and an inability to interact with
light which fit well with the
description of dark matter
but since we can't observe them we can't
be certain that they're there
physicists are trying to detect dark
matter through experiments on earth and
observations of the universe
but even with modern advancements in
science we haven't been able to pinpoint
exactly what dark matter is the search
for the missing matter remains one of
the biggest
unsolved problems in physics and it
waits for someone to solve it
[Music]
you